ever since will smith infamously slapped
and cursed out chris rock at the 94th
annual academy awards over a joke the
comedian made regarding smith's wife
jada pinkett smith and her alopecia
diagnosis events have unfolded rapidly
on march 28 2022 following news that the
academy of motion picture arts and
sciences had opened a formal review of
his behavior smith issued a public
apology via his social media he admitted
that his actions at the ceremony were
quote unacceptable and inexcusable and
expressed regret over his loss of
emotional control while this is
certainly a step in the right direction
it's not the punctuation mark on the
situation it may appear to be the
academy's board of governors convened an
emergency meeting that wednesday to
begin the review process and assess
what's next for smith possible
consequences may have ranged from being
bad attendants from future events to
expulsion from the academy altogether
some in the public have called for these
and other similar punishments and many
have even advocated for the revocation
of smith's first ever oscar for best
actor which he was awarded minutes after
assaulting rock for his performance in
king richard although academy governor
whoopi goldberg has come forward to
emphasize that they have no intention of
considering this as an option as the
academy continues to deliberate will
smith has repeatedly acknowledged the
widespread harm his actions caused and
accepted the potentially severe
consequences of his behavior taking a
bold step in the process in a statement
obtained on april 1 will smith once
again took responsibility for his attack
on chris rock calling his actions quote
shocking painful and inexcusable but he
didn't stop there smith also took the
drastic step of resigning his academy
membership as is this move leaves him
unable to vote on future oscar
ceremonies and participate in other
academy events it remains to be seen if
he'll still be allowed to present the
award for best actress next year seeing
as that's traditionally the previous
year's best actor winner's
responsibility in his missive smith
noted that he had responded to the
disciplinary hearing notice issued by
the academy and said that in addition to
his resignation he would quote accept
any further consequences the board deems
appropriate smith's statement continued
the list of those i have hurt is long
and includes chris his family many of my
dear friends and loved ones all those in
attendance and global audiences at home
i betrayed the trust of the academy
i deprived other nominees and winners of
their opportunity to celebrate and be
celebrated for their extraordinary work
i am heartbroken he adds that he seeks
to change in the wake of this event and
is willing to do what he must to ensure
that he changes his ways for the better
echoing sentiments that jada pinker
smith shared in a social media post that
promoted healing going forward shortly
after news of will smith's resignation
reached the public he received a direct
response to his motion academy president
david rubin accepted smith's tender of
resignation but clarified in a statement
that he's not off the hook yet ruben
said we will continue to move forward
with our disciplinary proceedings
against mr smith for violations of the
academy's standards of conduct the
academy's board will convene once again
on april 18th to determine further
consequences for smith though one has to
wonder how his departure from the
academy will affect their verdict
smith's resignation comes on the heels
of the revelation by oscar's producer
will packer that the los angeles police
department had sent officers to the
scene ready to arrest smith but were
told not to by rock who was reportedly
in high spirits after the incident in
fact he even joked that he took a punch
from muhammad ali in reference to
smith's turn as a late boxing legend in
2001's ali after rock declined to press
charges pakka stopped academy staff from
ejecting smith out of the event and the
rest is history what effect the debacle
will have on will smith's acting career
is uncertain though some say there's
hope for a rebound if he avoids becoming
a tabloid headline for the foreseeable
future then again as the situation has
proven already there are likely plenty
more twists and turns ahead that for all
anyone knows could adversely impact
smith's career all we can do is wait and
see what happens next check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about the oscars are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]